Martin's Acyclic Dependency Principle states that the dependencies between
packages must not form cycles. Expressed in terms of D.S.M.'s this
says that you should be able to permute the rows and columns of the D.S.M.
in such a way that the transitive closer of the matrix is lower triangular.
What this means is that there's a strict ordering among the Components,
such that a Component only depends on other components beneath it,
and never on one above it. A violation of this property is seen in
a system where component A depends upon component B,
and component B depends directly or indirectly on component A.
Not only is it difficult to maintain such systems it is even hard to
understand them in other words, you can't understand A without understanding B,
and you can't understand B without understanding A. There are several ways to
deal with violations of the Acyclic Dependency Principle. If you have
a situation where A depends on B and B depends on A, you can invent a module C,
take the part of A that B depends on and place it in C, and have both A and
B depend upon C. Another way to break the cycle where the packages
are siblings is to add an interface class into b and have a implement it.